un petit show au mode maintenant et en
musique s'il vous plaît ce n'est pas
après tout si fréquent il s'agit du
nouveau look que la poste veut donner à
ces hommes et à ces femmes de lettres
c'est à dire à nos facteurs regardez
fr3 et les fêtes et et vous convie tu as
ce défilé de mode dont vous serez les
derniers styliste
regardez bien vous trouver prochainement
dans mon quotidien régionaux ses croquis
et ses photos relatif au nouveau look
masculin et féminin de nos facteurs vous
devez envoyer vos cartes postales
désignant votre modèle préféré avant le
6 décembre dans les bureaux des frais tt
de montreux région qui lui aura belle
aux trois gagnants à ce jeu un par
région qui recevront chacun un livret de
caisse des fign le montant de 2000
francs note importante des chiens
amateurs de fonds de culotte de facteurs
ne sont pas autorisés à participer aux
us
c'est
m
là